Sweden's hate registry..??
Okay..
Okay.
JonTron.
That makes sense.
He's a Nazi.
(scary sound effects)
Pooderpie..?
No..
(sad gasp)
Why?
Why are we still he-- (laughs)
Kaz: Just to suffer..
Just.
(inhales)
Sweden!
Kaz: Every night.
Kaz: I can feel my leg.
Why?!
Kaz: My arm..
Why, Sweden, why?!
Kaz: Even my fingers.
I can't talk right now.
Why Lisa? Why Lisa? Please talk to me, please!
Kaz: The body I've lost...
Kaz: The comrades I've lost!
(Metal Gear Solid V Kaz Miller speech grows)
Kaz: It won't stop hurting!
The part of my life, you are everything.
I could not go on without you Lisa.
Kaz: It's like they're all still there.
The government's database..!
Kaz: You feel it too, don't you?
Has me!
On the hate registry.
You are lying! I nearly hit you.
You are tearing me apart Lisa!
What did I do?
What the fuck did I do?
Why do you hate me Sweden?
(trashing)
Okay. Let's start the video.
What the fuck are you guys doing here?
Revel mode is over.
Ge-get out.
Get out.
It's done.
Oh! You're here.
(laughs)
♫  Ano kousaten de  ♫
( What if everyone skipped down )
♫  Min’na ga moshi SUKIPPU wo shite  ♫
( Along the city streets that run all throughout the town )
♫  Moshi ano machi no man’naka de  ♫
( Imagine if we met up in the city’s heart )
♫  Te wo tsunaide sora wo miagetara  ♫
( And one by one we held hands and looked up the sky )
♫  Moshimo ano machi no dokoka de  ♫
( Imagine if you’d look around from where you stand )
♫  [ “PONPONPON” / Kyary Pamyu Pamyu ]  ♫
I've got exciting news!
I've got great news!!
EVERYBODY GET READY!!
*KYARY GETS EXTREMELY QUIET*
Oh, jeez...
*Kyary starts over the song*
OH GOD.
Well, whatever. I'm starting -
my own company!
This is a huge announcement for me.
And..!
I'm hiring.
That's right.
That's right!
I know this may come as a little shock for everyone, but I have left BuzzFeed.
I'm starting a new business.
I think it's gonna be great.
Y-y-yeah. I got great hopes for this one.
The underwater rats?
Fuck 'em.
Okay?
I'm sure I can do something with them in the future but for now...
I'm starting my new company.
But to start this new company, I'm gonna need some inspiration on start-ups.
(i got bored)
How do they do it, How do start ups get Millions and millions of dollars?
Without really having an interesting product or having like me no product whatsoever. Let's have a look
There's a company that rates 120 million million!! Let's let's look at that product
Making juice is easy
Start by taking a stroll down to the neighborhood farmers market by about 50 dollars worth of organic fruits and vegetables
$50 *Sarcastically* excuse me is that $50 worth of vegetables?
What are you fucking talking about? That's like 2, 2 eu- Whatever okay? Let's just keep watching
What is this? Its a juicero, Im sorry I don't know what that word means
It's a- it's a doger. Oh, I'm sorry. I don't I don't know what that word means doger
Can you- can you. can you define that to me.
Its a doger
basically juicero is a
$400 bag squeeze you can't use that they basically juice that comes in packs and
You can't use anyone else's packs you have to use their packs
because if you spend
$400 on a fucking juicer, that's clearly not enough. Now bloomberg did an interesting discovery
Incredible
You can just squeeze the bag
Excuse me. I I don't like doing this so I would like to pay $400
Please. it used to cost $700 by the way
Incredible, wow. How much money did they raise?
Ohhhhh, I love how people get so mad when they found out how much I make and, just look at- just look at juices
okay, I
God damn it. I ain't making that juice money yet, okay?
So calm the fuck down. And we haven't even gotten to the most genius part yet. That it it squeezes bags for you?
Oh wait? if there's wait, there's more?There's nothing to clean no mess whatsoever
It's so easy that it makes the old way of juicing seem
Well... old. Why did I do all that other stuff [who] cares that's our past life. This is our new life
[to] Sarah
The easiest freshest most delicious way to get juice.
But I just have one question hey is it a duggar though guru so clearly
Clearly running a business has if this piece of shit can we get 10 and 20 million? I'm pretty sure my idea
it's Gonna get a
Lot more than and a lot more than that [weighs] it under water rats. [oh]
goddamn it.
aw
Okay
Well, it looks like I'm gonna have to come up with a better idea. [well], you know buzzfeed recently changed their name from Buzzfeed yellow
Buzzfeed yellow is now boldly (SHIT I KNEW THEY CHANGED THEIR NAME)so now buzzfeed is available, so welcome everyone. I'm launching
Buzzfeed yellow everyone. Thank you. Thank you, uh
where the fuck did he go ,,,..,,,,,..,.we got a very diversified?
Employ-  uh crowd of people so far did I mention my dog is black
*phone ringing*
Hello( its mE)
It's my lawyer. What do you mean? I can't call it buzzfeed yellow they still trademark odd okay? It's [fucked] this time. [oh]
That's fine. I'm [gonna] call it
buttfeed
Now that's stupid, buttfeet
Yes
buttfeet everyone
So I'm looking for
I'm looking for you guys. I obviously need to hire a diversified crowd, so so I asked you guys on Twitter to
Apply to my new job
my new company, buttfeet I asked you guys to fill in some simple questions, and now let's just review your
Applicants here, we go number one Big Mac
Ravioli what's your best friend's age 87 oh Pal?
Ernesto
Your gender apache helicopter. That's great
That's really great preferred pronoun [desu] the fuck does [that] mean if you were a crayon
What color would you be colors doesn't matter you're goddamn right it. They don't matter [unless]
[you're] hiring for the job. I'm sorry you didn't make the cut you fucking idiot colors matter a great deal all right
We have another [application] from mold dog another apache helicopter. That's great
We need one [of] those if you were a crayon, what color would you be?
Triangle all right this is looking good. So far. What would the name of your debut album be kazoo kid vol 1 well, that's that's
Clearly Fuckin taking I'm sorry you're out
Can I get some serious applicants here anything for you supplied your best [friend's] age 22 your gender male?
What are you [fuckin] gay? What I?
What what the fuck is that preferred pronoun legend if you were a crayon what color would you be white because?
The white Crayon is useless?
Well at least he's honest describe yourself in three words
fat and lazy
Anything for views, you're hired!!!1
Congratulations everyone you're one of the first people to join the proud, buttfeet thank you so much
Thank you so much. We're proud to have you aboard
hopefully you can do something about that Gender, but
That's in the future next applicant. We have my size
150 cream egg. What would the name of your debut album be yo it's your boy skinny penis, ha ha [hey]
It's your boy
Skinny penis wait your favorite kPOp band is appa
You're out what the fuck?
whats wrong with you. God damn it Krista griffin. If you were a crayon. What color would you be kpop hair gray you're
AANNOO TOOO SETAND-
fucking
This fucking thing
Congratulations
The [griff] the Griffin you're in buddy. look how many fucking
apache helicopters we got
We got a lot of apache helicopters applying that's really good. We need we [need] a --fucking hell. That's a lot
of apache -hehhe - helicopters
because
Okay, well luckily here. We have a female because we need you need at least one otherwise preferred pronoun
Lord [or] [shamar]. [oh] is that that naruto fucking guy zero deaths. This is actually really promising. Why do you want to work at McDonald's?
I left buzzfeed
Yes, you're in you're in buddy. We have gathered team of buttfeed
Congratulations, you start
*Subtle moan*
Right now get the (potty word). I am not paying you
What is this video about?
We need a logo for this endeavour. Let's just make one right now
We need a logo for buttfeet [alright], so we have a we have a butt here, and now we're slowly
slowly going to make sure that it's a-
Yes
Yes, that's it, buttfeed
Buttfeet everyone there it is
Excellent. We're going to make millions. I wonder how much buzzfeeds worth actually oh
oh my fucking God
*typing noises*
How do I-- how am I going to get funding even though I'm a rich millionaire. [that's] it's ridiculous
I could start a patreon [Kanye] [west] asked Mark Zuckerberg [1] Kelly mark Zuckerberg invest 1 billion dollar into Kanye west ideas okay?
Well, let's just
[alright], well that pretty much does it thank you. Thank you. We got the funding we got the shitty idea
We got the name and we got the applicants
*triple clap*